Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
Đỗ Bảo Nam Vlog video ngày hôm nay đâu
bạn hay blog sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách
thêm cột thêm dòng trong Word
giả sử như trên màn hình đâu Bảo Nam và
rock đã có sẵn một vài bây giờ mình sẽ
thêm một số dòng hoặc một số cột vào cái
bảng này
thì mình sẽ chia thành 2 trường hợp
trường hợp thứ nhất thêm một dòng hoặc
một cột
đối với các phiên bản gốc khác nhau thì
thao tác để thêm cột hoặc thêm dòng đều
tương tự nhau
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ thêm một cột nữa
vào sau cái cột số điện thoại này thì ở
cái đô này đâu bà làm lúc sẽ chia sẻ hai
cách
cách chất thao tác thì thành lũy ban đầu
tiên bạn hãy chọn vị trí Cần thêm ở với
Dạo này mình muốn thêm một cột nữa ở bên
phải lý do Vậy bạn hãy cưới chuột vào
cái cột số điện thoại
sau đó bất ngay bạn vào mấy đứa nào
ở đây bạn ý khi bạn Kích chuột vào bảng
thì bạn mới nhìn thấy cái tắc design và
Leo Nếu bạn để cho đó ngoài thì bạn sẽ
không nhìn thấy hai cái đó
do vậy bắt buộc bước thứ nhất bạn cần
phải chọn đúng vị trí Cần thêm cột hoặc
thân dòng
và bất cứ ai bạn vào like
và trợ một cái nữa chậm quý ở đây mình
sẽ in xếp một cột ở phía bên tay phải đó
là insolite
bạn nhìn vào cái cần này bạn nhìn thấy
đây là in rất cột con nếu ai cần như thế
này hãng xuất dòng và mình sẽ chọn
Insert like như vậy mình là thêm một cột
mới vào bên phải cột số điện thoại đi
từ tương tự trong trường hợp bạn thêm
dòng cũng vậy mới đầu bây giờ mình sẽ
thêm một dòng nữa vào sao bây dòng có số
thứ tự là hai thì bạn hãy đưa chuột vào
đúng cái dòng cần thêm
sau đó bạn vẫn vào lao
vào đây mình sẽ chọn thêm một dòng ở
dưới cái Dòng vừa rồi mình sẽ chọn lại
rất lâu
như vậy mình đã thêm một dòng mới vào
đúng vị trí mình đang cần và đây mình
phải nhập nội dung
tiếp theo mình sẽ chia sẻ tăng cách ngay
đó là sử dụng trên phải
ví dụ bây giờ mình ra thêm tiếp một còn
nữa ở đằng sau còn số điện thoại này thì
bạn không cần phải chọn vào cái bảng này
mà Bạn chỉnh Anh phải vào vị trí mà bạn
cần thêm cồn hoặc thêm dòng
sau đó bạn vào Insert
Nếu bạn muốn thêm một cột vào bên phải
vị trí bằng cây chuột thì bạn chọn
ssgroup to Write Và nếu bạn muốn thêm
sang bên trái bạn trò là tours
chưa Bạn muốn thêm dòng thì bạn cho nó
yên rất lâu và có hai lựa chọn đó là ở
trên và ở dưới cái vị trí mà bạn thấy
chuột ở đây mình sẽ thêm một cột ở phía
bên tay phải cột điện thoại ra bạn mình
chọn in giấc Called To Write
như vậy mình là thêm xong một
đối với trường hợp bạn thêm dòng cũng
hoàn toàn tương tự
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang nội dung thứ hai
đó là thêm nhiều cột hoặc nhiều dòng
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ thêm nhanh ba dòng
thì các bạn thực hiện ở
mức thấp nhất bạn Bôi đen số lượng dòng
cần thêm nhiều đây mình muốn thêm 3 dòng
thì mình sẽ Bôi đen 3 dòng
sau đó bằng cưới chuột phải
và chọn Insert
bạn có thể cho inject in the Pooh ở trên
hoặc ở dưới
hoặc bạn vẫn có thể vàng leo sau đó bạn
chọn Insert yêu hoa tà âm mưu
video ở đây mình sẽ thêm ở dưới các dòng
mà mình đã mô đen và mình sẽ chọn rằng
in sớm đi đâu
hoa bạn thấy mình đã thêm nhanh ba dòng
vào đúng vị trí mà mình đã bôi đen
tương tự Nếu bạn muốn thêm bao nhiêu
dòng thì bước thứ nhất bạn chỉ cần bôi
đen mới như dòng sau đó bạn vẫn thực
hiện theo cách thứ nhất hoặc Cách thứ
hai tùy theo sở thích của bạn
đối với trường hợp trong sau khi bạn
hiện hoàn toàn tương tự ví dụ bây giờ
mình muốn thêm nhanh hay cột thì các
bước bạn vẫn thực hiện tương tự đầu tiên
bạn có thể Bôi đen ngang 2 Cột nào đó
cần thêm
bạn phải mua lên toàn bộ nội dung của
cột hoặc chỉ Model một phần nào đó trong
hai câu này
sau đó bạn vẫn vào lao
và click và intous rợn internet hoặc
insta live để thêm cô ở bên trái hoặc
bên phải ví dụ bây giờ mình có thêm sang
bên trái khi bạn thấy mình đã thêm nha
ngay cột vào phía bên tay trái
và nếu bạn không muốn thêm nhiều cột
theo cách duy nhất thì bạn hoàn toàn có
thể sử dụng cách thứ 2
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ thêm 3 cột
thì bước thứ nhất bạn chọn số lượng cột
cần thêm
bạn nhớ Anh muốn thêm bao nhiêu một thì
bạn cần phải moral với nhiều cột Ví dụ ở
đây mình cần thêm ba hồn thì mình sẽ Bôi
đen mà cổ Đấy sau đó bạn cưới chuột phải
chọn Insert và chọn sức Chrome từ ép
hoặc dai theo ý muốn viết ở đây mình vẫn
chọn to drive để thêm cột ở phía bên đây
phải cái phần mình đã chọn
thì như bạn thấy mình đã thêm nhanh 3
cột
vào phía bên tay phải các cột mà mình đã
bôi đen
và như vậy trong nội dung video vào rồi
đâu bán hàng mới lốc vừa chia sẻ nhanh
với bạn cách thêm cột thêm dòng trong
Word và ở phía này mình chia sẻ hai cách
bạn có đầy thế lực một cột một dòng hoặc
nhiều cột nhiều dòng theo ý muốn
nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cần được hỗ trợ
bạn anh comment trực tiếp ở phía dưới
cái đầu này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video
Xin chào và Anh đang ở các video tiếp
theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ Bảo Nam với Đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các lô cũng từ đỗ vào Nam với Xin cảm ơn
các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn phải tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam với
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam blach.com
hoặc kênh YouTube để bàn ăn blocks để
xem thêm các video cũng như thủ thuật
máy tính tay calypso Cruiser
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bàn ăn bước chúng con
để cập nhật những bài viết mới nhất
các bạn đang theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo